so right over here we have the graph of
f and then we have four different
expressions and what i encourage you to
do is pause this video and see if you
can figure out which of these
expressions would give the largest
quantity the second largest quantity the
second smallest quantity and the
smallest quantity
so i'm assuming you have paused the
video and you've given an attempt now
let's work through this together
so this first expression right over here
we're taking the sum from i equals zero
to nine so we're actually taking the
we're actually taking the sum of ten
things because we're taking the zero
thing first second third all the way up
to nine so this is actually going to be
the sum of ten things because we're
starting at zero
and we start at f of negative five plus
zero
and so we're going to take
so it's going to be we're taking so
we're staying negative five f of
negative five plus zero so that's this
height right over here
that's that height
right over there so we're going to take
that and then when i equals 1 it's going
to be negative 5 plus
1 which is negative 4 so it's that
height right over there
and then negative 5 plus
2 when i equals 2 so it's going to be
that height right over there
so we're essentially going to sum up
all the way so this is going to be
negative 5
negative 5 all the way up to
so negative 5 all the way negative 5
plus 9 is going to get us all the way to
4 so it's going to be all the way over
there
all the way over there
and so you might be guessing how do i
relate this you know they've already
kind of made us think that we're going
to somehow relate this to area somehow
but how do we actually make that
relationship
because right now as this is written
it's just giving us a bench essentially
a bunch of
the values of the functions at different
points i guess you could say it's a lot
of these heights right over here
but one thing that you might that might
jump out at you is you could construct
rectangles all that have width one and
so if you multiply the height times the
width the area is going to be the same
thing as the height so if we put a 1
times 1 right over here this makes it
very clear that you're taking the height
times the width of
this rectangle and then this rectangle
so you essentially have a bunch of
left-handed
left-handed rectangles that you could
imagine are trying to estimate that's
this blue-ish this bluish area that was
shaded in and it's clearly going to be
an underestimate because it's giving up
it's giving up these areas it's giving
up those areas right over there all of
these rectangles are sitting they're
either just touching or they are below
the actual function so let me just write
this right over here this is going to be
an underestimate
underestimate
the area of this blue area
now let's think about what this one is
here so this is f
so it's the same thing that we're taking
the sum of we're starting at i equals 1
and we're going at 10.
so once again 10 things so negative 5
plus 1 is negative 4. f of that is this
line right over here
is that line right over there and so it
looks like it looks like we're taking
right-handed rectangles because we could
say times 1 so times 1 would be the area
if obviously if we multiply by 1 we're
not changing we're not changing the
value of this expression so that would
be the area of this first right-handed
rectangle then when i is equal to two
it's going to be f of negative three and
so you're looking at this one
right over here and so i can let me draw
at least
this part of it
so it's going to look something like
this it's going to look something like
this where now we're dealing with
right-handed rectangles and these are
clearly an over-estimate
these are right-handed rectangles
so you're going to go all the way when
when i is equal to 10 negative 5 plus 10
is 5 f of 5 that's this line right over
here or this length right over here f of
5 and of course we're multiplying it by
1.
so it's going to look like that and we
could keep going
i think you get the general idea now
these are all going to be right-handed
well these are all right-handed
rectangles that i've drawn and these are
going to be an over-estimate of the area
because they all have this little extra
they all have this extra region right
over here so these are going to be an
over
estimate
now let's think about this one right
over here this is we're going to start
at i equals 1 and we're going to go to
and it looks like we're going to do
rectangles instead of with one we're
going to do with one half
and once again since we're starting at i
equals one these look like right-handed
rectangles again this is that we're
going to use to estimate so let me do
this in a color that you can actually
see i'll do this in orange i'll do this
in orange right over here so the first
one's going to be negative 5
plus 1 half so it's going to be this f
of that which is going to get take you
right over there and then you're going
to multiply it times the width which is
one-half
so now we have twice as many
twice as many
right-handed rectangles so it's going to
look it's going to look like this
twice and i won't do all of them because
it takes some time
we're going to have twice as many
right-handed rectangles
so
it's still going to be an overestimate
over estimate
but it's going to be less of an
overestimate than this one over here
because this one over here you had all
of this extra green space above the
function now we have a lot less extra
space a lot less extra space
above the function so it's a better
estimate but it's still going to be an
overestimate because at least for this
function right over here because at
least over over this interval where the
function is increasing the right-handed
the right-handed rectangle is giving us
overestimate but this is a little bit
more precise because we're doing we're
using
we're using narrower rectangles to
estimate overestimate but less so
but less so than this one right over
here and this right over here this is
the definite integral from negative 5 to
5 of f of x dx and you can imagine this
is essentially the limit as we take
these widths to be smaller and smaller
and smaller and we essentially end up
having essentially an infinite number
where we approach an infinite number of
these right over here and this is the
actual area so this is what's actually
depicted in blue this is the actual
area
so if i were to list this from largest
to smallest the biggest overestimate
this is the this is the biggest
overestimate right over there now this
is still going to be an overestimate but
it's a little bit more precise because
we have more rectangles
so i'll put that 2. now this is the
actual area so i'll put that three and
then this is actually an underestimate
so i would rank this four this is the
largest of the values and this is going
to be the smallest of the values